our world is changing the mass
extinction we feared has already begun
and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world and unless all the
Titans are found our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
your goddamn minds I am sorry but this
is the only way
[Applause]
you monster
[Music]
long live the king
hey everybody is Charlie I got a bunch
of requests to do a Godzilla trailer
video so I'll explain what's going on
here but you may remember the Godzilla
king of monsters is the title of a 1956
Godzilla movie so they're borrowing from
that but the plot of that was very
different from the plot of this movie
it's applied that Godzilla is going to
be fighting these other monsters they
did say a couple things during the panel
and they talked a little bit about the
Godzilla vs. Kong movie that's coming in
the future so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's still a whole bunch
of comic-con stuff that I haven't got to
yet there's just way too much stuff to
do videos for everything right away so
the biggest thing first as you could
tell the setting of this movie is very
different from the setting of the first
film there's a time jump but Kenda
Watanabe is in the film he doesn't look
like he's that much older so a lot of
time has passed since the first film but
not that much time so it's not like he's
a grizzled 80 year old man he just looks
a couple years older so I'm guessing
that maybe like five plus years has
passed vir pharmakeia is implying in her
voiceover that there's been a bunch of
manmade ecological disasters and that's
what's causing the Titans as she calls
them the monsters to awaken again so
there's a couple things going on in here
you have two different groups you have
monarch that's trying to sort of
carefully protect the monsters but also
keep them from completely destroying
humanity but there's another separate
rival group to monarch that wants to use
the monsters for their own selfish ends
that captures her character and Millie
Bobbie Brown
Vera Farmiga is playing a scientist that
works for monarch she's one of the
protagonists obviously Godzilla's the
real hero of the film but she's one of
the good people she called her character
a DJ like a music radio DJ for the
monsters think of her as like the fight
commentator while they're all battling
each other for supremacy Millie Bobbie
Brown is her daughter Kyle Chandler who
you saw during the trailer is her
ex-husband so there's sort of the good
people ken watanabe is also a good
character too so you have monarch people
you have this other evil organization
that wants to control the monsters and
use them to control the planet but the
basic idea of this voice over is is that
humanity is a plague they've caused all
these disasters the titans are like the
avatars of nature they're the true
custodians of the planet they're coming
back to wipe out the plague so
throughout the trailer you see them
sort of uncovering all these undersea
locations you see the carvings of
ancient people worshipping Godzilla then
there's this big underground temple with
an exorcist Easter Egg this statue is
right out of the Exorcist movie all this
underground ancient culture stuff is
just to provide context for what's
happening in present day people used to
worship the Titans as gods they went
into hibernation these civilizations
died off people forgot about them the
planet went to [ __ ] so now they're
coming back to remind everyone who
really rules the planet who the real
dominant species is even if you're not a
big Godzilla fan you probably recognized
at least a couple of the monsters that
appeared the Director of T's that there
were also be other monsters besides the
ones that we see but the big ones we see
Ghidorah in the big block of ice the big
three-headed dragon
there's Rodin with the giant wings and
then there's Mothra I believe that this
is Mothra
when Milly Bobby Brown is touching its
snout just because of the cocoon here
underground you may have also spotted
the John Carpenter thing Easter egg so
the thing movie takes place at Ice
Station 31 in the Arctic when Milly
Bobby Brown and VFR Magee's characters
are walking up to this Arctic station
here it's station 31 so what is the plot
of the thing movie they unfreeze a
monster from a block of ice it's really
an alien from another planet it kills
them all we see a couple of these
monsters in giant glaciers like Ghidorah
and what looks like Mothra so it's
almost like the monsters are the thing
from another world like the John
Carpenter movie they might wind up
killing us all so it implies a much
darker ending for the movie because the
ending of the thing movie really did
make it seem like Kurt Russell's
character was gonna die you may have
also detected the Claire de Lune music
track that was playing on the trailer
that's French for light of the moon I
believe that's a reference to Godzilla's
atomic breath because it's blue light
blue like the light of the Moon
illuminating the sky so obviously this
is all about man being the villain of
the film Godzilla being the hero the
monsters are the real heroes but
technically Godzilla is the hero because
he's the king of monsters if they
haven't really teased much of why
Godzilla is going to be battling these
other monsters but I'm assuming it has
something to do with this other evil
organizations that's trying to control
them but for those of you asking where's
Tom Hiddleston's character because he
joined monarch at the end of the Kong
Skull Island
I think the reason why he's not in this
movie is just because he was busy
filming infinity war and Avengers 4 so
when they do that Kong vs. Godzilla
movie in the future that's what he'll
probably come back for don't forget brie
Larson Captain Marvel was part of that
too because she's blowing up big time
she was a big actress before she was in
Kong Skull Island but she's only gonna
get bigger so of course they'll probably
try to get her to come back for that too
so we'll have a little Marvel reunion
the next time we get a Godzilla movie as
far as I know they haven't put a date on
that yet so no idea when Godzilla is
going to fight King Kong but apparently
it's sometime in the next couple of
years the trailer looks great I love
that they're going full Godzilla they
did say that there would be twice as
many Godzilla scenes as there were in
the first film I think when they did the
last one they were a little bit worried
about introducing that to Western
audiences so they wanted to ease into
Godzilla but now they're really making
it a genuine kaiju film and trying to
honor the legacy of the Godzilla movies
like I said Bear McCreary is actually
doing the music for the film he said
he's gonna try and incorporate music
from that original 1956 king of the
monsters film so if you're a long time
Godzilla fan or a kaiju film fan they're
definitely going for the member berries
with a lot of this stuff but I also
think that they're trying to introduce a
lot of new people to the idea of these
big Kaidu films post all your reactions
in the comments I'm a like this is
really about the monsters battling so
I'm tuning my expectations accordingly
like I'm not quite as worried about the
rest of the film we'll see how these big
kaiju battles come up it should be
pretty cool there's a bunch more Comic
Con videos that I'm working on I'll try
to post that stuff as soon as possible
leave your requests in the comments
below - click here to rewatch the Shazam
and the Aquaman trailers and click here
to rewatch that flash season 5 trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you